all right we're doing another ask Dave
Rubin so here we go at Alice Ruiz I
asked me what do you think of hashtag
Jess we Milo alright so if you guys
don't know about this Milo you Napoles
who's actually a former guest on the
rubin report he had his twitter
verification the little blue check next
name he had it removed by twitter this
week and it's apparently the first time
that they've taken away the blue check
as sort of retribution for not liking
what somebody saying on twitter they
banned accounts before they've suspended
accounts but they took away the
verification of the verification all
that does is say that he actually is the
real milo innopolis which as i've sat
across from him he actually is the real
one now there's a billion accounts that
are that are faking to be him which I'm
finding very irritating in my mentions
so what do I think about it look it's
not censorship in that they're not
stopping him from being on Twitter
they're not telling him what he can and
cannot say but it does seem like a bit
of a tough and an odd move by a social
media organization to remove someone's
verification it's obviously a punitive
measure they don't like some of the
things he's talking about now look he
goes out of his way to offend people
that's his whole thing I welcome you to
watch our video that we did together he
offends everybody he was promoting a
hashtag feminism is cancer just a couple
weeks ago that's his thing right like he
wants to offend everybody he's a
provocateur
so should Twitter have done this I don't
think so I like my blue check please
don't take my blue check away from me
Twitter and I think in a weird way they
end up just strengthening some of the
ideas that he's really just pushing out
there for the conversation so I think
it's a silly move by Twitter and it's
not helping whatever they're trying to
help but it's not it's not a First
Amendment issue right cuz it's not the
government and it's barely a free speech
issue because they're not taking away
his ability to say what he thinks but I
do like Milo and I'm gonna have him on
the show again and we disagree on stuff
and that's fine Nick asks what do you
think is reza aslan 'he's motivation to
lie
perfect timing on this one I just talked
to David pac-man so we're gonna put a
link right down below
you can find out David Pakman did a
great video dissecting reza aslan the
guy is a notorious liar he made up his
credentials he's just someone that
should not be relevant to any public
discussion and i'm not a fan of his in
case he can't tell i dan simpson said
i've noticed on a few occasions
you refer to bernie sanders as a
socialist instead of a democratic
socialist is this intentional why it's
not really intentional i think actually
if bernie was being a hundred percent
truthful he would describe himself as a
socialist right but you're not gonna win
the presidency describing yourself as a
socialist at least not in america in
2016 maybe in twenty twenty four or
something so he has to describe himself
as a socialist Democrat or a democratic
socialist that whatever that is I don't
think it really matters you know I
always say to you guys like let's not
get too hung up on the terms but I think
Bernie basically is a socialist and if
you really got him in like his most
honest moment I think he that's what he
would say at metal atheists asked what
is the best way to engage in a
conversation with a close-minded theist
I would say by the book by my former
guest Peter Bogosian a manual for
creating atheists he literally lays it
out that is the entire point of the book
and it's not about attacking them and
it's not about mocking them they're
allowed to have different views
everybody's allowed but it's about how
do you open those conversations and talk
to people in a rational honest way about
your ideas but maybe they'll convince
you saying that you didn't know about
all right at McNiel asked what is your
favorite sci-fi or fantasy novel I think
I would say and I don't know how high up
this goes on the litany of sci-fi novels
but contact which was written by Carl
Sagan who's an incredible scientist as
you guys all know I hope an author who
wrote a million great books that were
non-fiction but it was his one fiction
book which eventually was a movie with
Jodie Foster and there's a lot of
interesting differences between the
movie and the book and it's sort of it's
science fiction but it's also very much
based in fact sort of like the Martian
which i think is pretty cool
Zach F asked I'm going to college
year I'm curious what you think is the
best way to combat anti-semitism on
campus without being branded a bigot I'd
love to know your thoughts I thought
this was an interesting question because
how to combat anti-semitism without
being labeled a bigot
so you're saying how do I stop people
from hating Jews without people saying
that I'm a bigot there's some odd logic
in that
but I guess that's sort of how things
work out as I would say in any thing
whatever the the minority group that
you're trying to defend is pretty much
everybody's just humans and you really
just got it just sort of if you if you
stand for basic liberal human principles
whatever your religion is whatever your
color is whatever your race is then
that's sort of what will rise to the top
I know that's probably not the greatest
answer in the world but I think I think
that's a good jumping-off point at alan
dlg said hey Dave I've lived in a great
and loving Christian home all my life so
I've always been pretty comfortable with
the concept of death you live a good
Christian life you die and then you go
to heaven forever very comforting stuff
it wasn't until recently that I started
to question the things that I had
believed my whole life the one thing
that seems to be holding me back from
saying that I'm full-on agnostic atheist
is death it's incredibly terrifying to
me and I think about it every day I know
it's something all men before me have
done and that I have to face it at some
point I guess what I'm trying to ask is
how do you deal with this and what
comforts you when you think of death
thank you
I don't think about death that often I
really don't I know if I watched a lot
of Woody Allen movies I would I have
watched a lot of Woody Allen movies and
it always seems kind of silly we're here
right this second so I have no idea what
happens when you die and I just really
can't worry about it that much and it
would seem crazy to me to do that like
you got you got to do it while you're
here and finally at k3t I said what
music do you listen to I'm big on 80s
classic rock I just went to a journey
concert a couple months ago love
Fleetwood Mac I listened to a lot of
jazz I listened to a lot of ambient
stuff I like the Cafe Del Mar channel on
Pandora not a huge fan of words
in general in music so there you go
alright guys thanks for playing along
and we'll do another one of these next
week